あの子と心にも
時よりも
ちょっと緊張しまして
えー今日話したい内容は
一つ
人生のスイッチをいつ入れるかということであります
これは言うまでもないことだと思いますけれども
まあ未来を拓くための担い手はここにお集まりの
ちょっと若くないかと思いますけど皆さんのような若い人たちです
で
アカルイミライ新たな未来を創造するためにはみなさんが悔いのない人生を選んで頂か
なければいけないかと思います
でそのときに
5その人生のターニングポイントを迎えるかもすでに
ターニングポイントを迎えてあの自分の目標に向かって頑張っておられる方もおられる
かと思います
ただ
まだこの自分の目標が決められずにいる方も何人かはおられるかと思います
今日は自分の経験
をもとにいいそのターニングポイントを迎えた時にどのような判断をするかというよう
なことを
紹介させていただいて少しでも参考になればと思っております
今後人生の転機を迎えるであろう皆さんへのエール
の草履です
まず
他の人の例を参考にしてみたいと思います
例えばこれはアメリカの情報関連企業の起業者の
例ですけども
マイクロソフトを
をつくったビルゲイすそれからポールアレン
彼らはそれぞれ
19歳と22歳の時に会社を立ち上げてます
それから apple
スティーブンジョブスとスティヴンを自虐彼らはそれ全21歳と25歳の時にいい
コンピューターを最初に作っています
それからティムバーナーズリーこの方はあのご存じない方もおられるかと思います
けれども
インターネットの world wide web http プロトコルの最初に
作った人です
この方ちょっと来い
年がいってるんですが実は最初のアイディアっていうのはもう25歳の時に出されて
いるんですね
それからあジェリー案とデビッド filo
彼らはあドクターの学生の時にヤフーを立ち上げました
それから
マークザッカーバーグに至っては18歳大学に入ってすぐ
facebook
大立ち上げたんですね
まあこれ実は皆さんと同じくらいの年齢で起業をしている方を集めたんですけれども
この世界を変えるような仕事をしている人っていうのは
20代のうちから人生をかけているんだなということがお分かりいただけるかと思い
ます
でこのような
人生の方向を決める
いうのは何がきっかけになるかということですけども
たぶんアメリカの企業家たちは
まあもちろん自信もあったでしょう
ただ心の底から湧き出る捏造というものに従って
自分の人生を変えたんじゃないかなと思います
ただ
必ず所がこういう例ばかりではありません
私の周りでも
例えば
父親とか母親が会社をやっていてそれができなくなって
自分が繋が注がなければいけなくなったという人もたくさん見てきました
それから経済的に非常に大変な状況にいたので
まあ夢をしてて
就職しなければいけないという人もたくさん見てきました
でさらに
まあこれ一番者がの私の兵ですけどなんとなくやってたらこんなになっちゃったという
ような人もいるかもしれません
ただ私のような場合前をですね
1回だけ
非常に転機となり色な経験をしました
まず
この大学でどのようにしの下したかということを紹介させて頂きますと
ここまでは本当に勉強が嫌いで何のために勉強しているのか分からなかったんです
けれども大学でこの勉強をすることのいいっていうのを教えてもらって
そこからも抗議は非常にどれもが楽しくなりました
だから一生懸命勉強しました
それから特に熱中していたのは
マイコン今のパーソナルコンピューター pc ですね
アルバイトをしてパソコンを買ってで自分でプログラミン
中をやってました
ただこの1年生から3年生まででは自分の人生を賭けるような出来事
いうのには出会うことはありませんでした
で一つのきっかけになったのが卒業研究です
私の恩師や華咲先生が企業から名古屋大学に移られて
で研究室を立ち上げられました
そこで見た卒業研究のテーマ青色 led というのに私は強く惹かれました
っていうのは当時
ディスプレイはすべてブラウン管でしたので非常に大きいもので電力もものすごく
かかるものでした
それが青色 led にしたら非常にスマートなものになる
ということはわかったんですね
ということで
もしこれをやれば
世の中を変えられるに違いないっ
もちろんこのテーマが非常に難しいことであるということは全く理解はしてません
この re ですけども当時どういう状況だったかと言いますと
実は最初にこの青色 led をつくったのは我々ではなくてこのパンコフという
アメリカの科学者
生まれは統合なんですけどアメリカに移り住んで
アメリカで成功された方です
1971年にこの led を作りました
ただその時には効率が
不十分で実用化されませんでしたけれどもこの
閉校をきっかけに世界中の多くの
研究者たちが実用化に取り組んだんですね
例えば rca というのはアメリカの会社です
それから日本では沖電気日立
それから松下今のパナソニックですね
ヨーロッパではフィリップ
いう世界に名だたる研究者等起業家が
この材料の実用化を目指しました
ですけど残念ながら全て失敗に終わりました
ですので1970年代というのは青色 led にとっては不難の時代であったわけ
です
私は学部の4年生から
この研究を
始めさせてもらいました
当然もし動物ですから
もう見よう見まねで例えばいろいろな研究室を訪れて
装置の見学等をさせていただきましたそれで急いで
大学に帰って装置の改造
それからも実験を何回も繰り返しということで実験回数は1500回を超えました
まあただそれでもいくらやってもすまっつの粒のような汚い決勝しかあできませんし
で
ここでですね一番大きな転機がわたしにとって打つ
訪れました
ほとんど成果が出てないにも関わらず御社の赤崎先生はドクターへの進学を勧めてくれ
たんですね
私にとっても本当に実はうれしくて
結果は出てないんですけども実験を楽しくてしょうがないんですよ
だからなんとかこう続けたいなと思ってたところにこうやって声をかけていただいたの
で本当に嬉しくて
ドクターに進学しようと思ったんですね
ただその
それが8月ですそこから
10月
自分にとってはとんでもない出来事が発生したんですね
まあ
二国に振られる皆さんはもっと大変なご経験をしている方もおられるかと思いますけど
マッサーの時まで私って本当に何不自由なく暮らしてきたんですよ特に
経済的には何の問題もなく
う暮らしてきましたんですけどその時にいい
10月にですね
まあ経済っていうか自分の生活を支えてくれて
人がその
まあ会社を辞めてしまって
で全く生活の支えを失ってしまったんですね
でへ
まあ私ですねあの
気楽に生きるというのを隣接そう
第一の目的にしていますから
今までずっと気楽に来てたんですけどこの時だけは真剣に悩みました
道具子やっ
考えたことはまぁ当時は
まあ私長男なんですね長男だからやっぱり実家の家計を守らないといけないなぁとか
です
あるいは元気も実は何も成果出てないのにほんとどう欲しいほかと
でものすごく悩んだんですけども最終的には
先ほどアメリカの企業家のれいむを見ていただきましたけど
多分
本当に人間が創造力を発揮できるっていうのは若い頃だけなんですね
だから
その時に考えたのは自分は人生賭けるのはこれが最後のチャンスかもしれないと
だからどうしても研究を続けたいと
思ったんですね
当時の
自分というか若い頃は自分を知っている人はもう
絶対そんなことは考えられないと思いますけれども
でもどういうわけかその時だけは研究を続けたいと思ったんですね
で幸いにしてドクターに入ってから奨学金を受けられるということが分かりまして
で研究を続けることができました
まあこれは偶然も重なったんですけれども
就寝の2年の時
非常にきれいな結晶を作ることができました
それからドクターの3年間ではできなかったんですがその後城主になって初めて
p 型の結晶それから pn 接合のダイオードを作ることに成功しました
私が
学生の頃
考えていたのはもうディスプレイの王様だけです
それがあ
ある
企業の技術者の方がこの青色 led これに
a この蛍光体をを組み合わせるだけで簡単に
この白色 led ができると
いうことを見つけられまして
でこの青色 led の応用範囲っていうのはもう
楽団に広がったんですね
でも全くを予想もしてなかったんですけれども
一般照明にまでこの技術が使われるようになっちゃったっ
正直びっくりです
あの2020年までにはですね日本で総発電量のうちの7%
電力料金にしますと1兆円
の節電が可能になるというふうに言われています
これは本当に予想もしなかったことでした
さて位
さらにですね
嬉しいことには
今
例えば目中央アフリカとか
アジアですね
まだまだ
電力需要がを電力網が整備されていなくて
例えば夜
勉強したり
本を読んだり
子どもたちができない地域が世界にはあります
そういった
国々の
子どもたち特に子供たちに
例えば
この青色 led と先ほどの蛍光体ん
さらにバッテリーと
太陽電池の組み合わせで簡単な
光源
照明が提供できるということで
まあ自分が入っただけではないんですけども
それに関わるものとして非常に嬉しく思っております
さていっ
今日の主役はああ
皆さん若い人たちです
ぜひ
これを機会にでして自分の人生
5スイッチを入れるかということについて a
考えて頂ければと思います
まあ普通に考えますとですね
大学で勉強したことをもとにしてどのように社会に活かすかいう考え方があります
まあどちらかというと基礎からずっとっ子積み上げていくボトムアップ的な考え方です
ね
少し視点を変えて見て今度は
社会を眺めてみて
じゃあ自分が何ができるかという風に考えて
見ることも
非常に
面白いアイディアが生まれるきっかけになるかと思います
例えば
今
人口の増加が大きな問題になっています
もう70億人を超えました
ゼロから10億人以上になるまでに
10万円以上の
時間が経っていますところが60億から70億同じ10億なんですけど
だった12年で
6帖から7ジョークまで増えちゃったんですね
で
地球の
人類のキャパシティというのはだいたい150億が限度といわれています
こういった問題に対して例えば食料とか水をどのようにするか
あるいは
gdp 日本はそんなに度見てないから心配する必要ないんですけど
世界では大きく伸ばしているところがあって
電力が2025年ぐらいには足りなくなるのではないかと心配されています
そういった問題に対して
どのように解決するか
環境破壊環境問題
地球温暖化というのは実はをじわりじわりと
我々の生活を支えていて今までは
北の国では
その細菌の発生というのが問題にならなかったために水の浄化システムもあまり
必要なかったんですねそれが実は地球温暖化の影響で北国でも
水の浄化システムというのが大きな問題になりつつあります
そういった問題をどうやって解決するか
さらにますべての人が健康に暮らすにはとかですね
あるいは
日本でも大きな原発事故がありましたけどそういった事故をなくすためにはどうしたら
いいかということを考えると
我々てまだやらなければいけないことがいっぱいあるなということが
お分かりいただけるかと思います
ということで皆さん若い人にはとくにですね
5自分のスイッチを押す書く
どこでを救っ
されは
ここで小いくことで終わりにしたいと思うどうもありがとうございます
です